okay so thank you so much to praise SF
for inviting me and thank you all for
staying on a Sunday afternoon to look at
some pictures and projects the artists
are doing in this field let me just get
my slides up yes so as Cecilia mentioned
I look at this field of creative AI and
I run the creative AI meetup here in
London I sometimes double and creating
up myself and I create exhibitions and
research what startups and corporates
are doing in the space and today I'm
going to give you an overview of how
various machine and deep learning
techniques are used in in the field of
art and I'm mainly sticking to visual
art because that's my third form and if
you look at the mainstream interest in
the space I think it really kicked off
with with deep dream which came out of
Google about three years ago and I trust
most of you familiar with this but if
you're not here is an image of an artist
called Momo Acton and you can see how
his photograph transforms into this
image with lots of multicolored dogs and
pagodas because the neural network works
to emphasize the features in the image
and other artists such as Mike tyka have
created work in the space and also
Daniel embrace who actually combined the
techniques of deep dream with
computational photography so you can see
that the images they're still somewhat
realistic and kind of very high quality
but the deep dream swirls are still
visible
then came the technology of star
transfer which jean has done a lot of
work and so can playing around with how
you can transform a Mona Lisa painting
into a cubist or a pointillist artwork
or even look at how you can change it
into the style of Google Maps or kind of
calligraphy
so yeah style transfer has been very
popular in the technical community I
think but the artistic field sees it a
little bit differently yeah that there
are a bit wary of it in some ways and so
whenever I actually talked to curators
or computer on computational creativity
researchers and in this in this space
they're always complaining that they're
in the technical community there is so
much interest in playing around with
style transfer and apps such as Prisma
to create aesthetical degree work that
is aesthetically pleasing but there is
kind of little novelty or meaning in it
from the outside so that's kind of
sometimes their perspective but I think
there are many ways how you can
interestingly use the ideas of style
transfer particularly if you move beyond
the if you move beyond kind of this
impressionist or pointless aesthetic to
something like jeans examples here of
using Google Maps or of combining styles
and moving on there is there's an artist
called Terence Broad who reconstructed
the film Blade Runner frame by frame
using a variational auto encoder so you
can see the reconstructed version on the
right and it reconstructs some some
parts of the film
better than others but still is somewhat
far from perfect but either way this
work got a copyright infringement notice
from Warner Brothers when it was put up
online so it's quite interesting that
this shows that clearly that the
algorithm used by Warner Brothers to
detect fakes and pirate art works up
online and decided that this can have
this work which is still quite blurry to
my eye and I would want to watch Blade
Runner like this is a film that it still
was pretty much like a pirate or a copy
in their eyes there's another artist
called Ben Bogart who trained a
different type of model on and yeah on
Blade Runner still and I think this was
yes some statistical methods and yeah
you can see it's much more angular and
in aesthetics quite different
say what Terry Broad has done and then
if we think of artists looking at
identity or the human form then
generative adversarial networks have
provided plenty of opportunities for
artists to kind of play around with this
technology and one of the more popular
artists is Myra Clingerman who on a
day-to-day basis very much experiments
with the latest models to generate
various images so I particularly like
these ones because they are reminiscent
to perhaps early 20th century painting
and whenever I speak to my art world
colleagues they see Francis Bacon or egg
on Sheela or other artists as being an
inspiration for this work but if you ask
Mario Clingerman he will say that No
he didn't think of these artists all he
did was kind of plug in at data phase a
database of thing this was unsuitable
for work images and then he got these
kind of weird forms that are clearly
very very reminiscent of the human form
but not quite perfect and the same with
with these images whether eye or the
mouth can be lopsided and some of his
further experiments also also include
kind of black and white versions and
artists such as Mike Tyco have also done
work which is kind of much more much
more realistic and probably similar to
what you can now get with I think it was
Sullivan that came out from Nvidia that
can generate lots of images of celebrity
faces and now I wanted to give you a
couple of examples of artists who work
with their own data sets so these
artists starting with Roman Lipsky they
actually made their own data sets so
Roman Lipsky took lots of photos of yeah
various scenery in Los Angeles and then
he he trained confident so generates
kind of images from that based on his
style and I think these are some of the
paintings from Roman Lipsky and this is
what the neural network has been
generating kind of and then this later
on as as Roman Lipsky has been plugging
in some of his generator so some of his
drawings into
kind of neural network to generate
further images and then he drew these
again so these are the generates images
and this is one of his drawings so I
think this is interesting because yes
it's an example of an artist who is kind
of thinking about the importance of data
and how you can influence that in kind
of creating a future work and then also
what it teaches you and it surprise you
to do with your own practice and there
is also an artist called
Anna Riddler who who watched this film
called Fall of the House of Usher and
it's 1929 black-and-white film based on
an Edgar Allan Poe book and Anna maids
300 ink drawings like scene here based
on the film and then she yes she used
fixed depicts so one of these gun models
to generate images in her style and this
is this is kind of the generated
animation and I've I know Anna very well
and I always kind of asked her about
this project and she tells me that for
her it was an interesting experiment to
see what the Picts depicts generates
from her work and what this tells her
about her own practice so for example
she has now noted that there are certain
objects that she forgets in images so
there's I think I'd share that appears
and reappears sometimes in the sequence
because to her it's not important and
some sudden she's forgets it and then in
in in in the in the face sometimes she
draws the eyes and the eyebrows very
similarly and this is also obvious and
results of what the neural network has
generated and then there is an artist
called Patrick Tracy who has this robot
that draws images of people and I think
he accumulated a dataset of maybe 10 or
20,000 drawings it's quite a lot and
then 21,000 drawings and then he got
picks two picks to generate some images
of gonna face us back from these
drawings and there is this always
forgetting to pronounce it but there's
this type of art that there can also you
can also be used to feed into the neural
networks and then generate images that
are completely kind of joint and clear
and these were done by Osamu I could
qiyamah
and now if we look at artistic projects
that think more about recognizing and
classifying images there is this takes
ika prize which compares a contemporary
photojournalism so that's the image on
the left two photos from the Tate's
collection and yeah there are some
examples where you can see the inside of
a kind of BMW car is compared to an
Henry Moore sculpture or you have an
image of kind of somebody sitting in
front of a screen compared to a scholar
so there are a couple of interesting
comparisons that can view you might
initially not expect to see and there is
an artist and researcher called Tom
white who used
yeah who created images that pass as
certain categories according to various
models and so it's nice here this is not
a sewing machine but this image past as
a sewing machine in Inception v3 vgg 16
and and other models so it's kind of
showing how the machines I can recognize
it as a sewing machine whereas to a
human it's like not a sewing machine and
here this is an example of an electric
fan kind of same again recognizes an
electric fan and all these kind of
various models and then there is an
artist called George award Dyer who drew
various images you know kind of
calligraphy style and then yeah passed
them through an image recognition model
to figure out what they can be
recognized as and this is an example of
a fountain for example so in this image
one of the models saw a fountain and on
the right are the kind of the features
of the points in an image that made the
network think it is a fountain and this
is a street sign
so in George's case it was interesting
to see how these neural networks derive
meaning from these random characters and
how they can also create something that
is in general and an essence of a street
sign so the minimum kind of components
you need for something to be a street
sign and there is this work by Sebastian
schmear which looks at how you classify
images into various categories including
the past and the future and the problem
and the
Ellucian so these images for example
they were noted by visitors of the
website as belonging to the category of
problem cc have children you have
nuclear power stations and things like
that for the solution you have parrots
and Arts Council England if you think
about the past you have ice cream you
have trees and sofas and for the future
have children and people with guns and
yeah
Lego t-shirts and then there are some
artists to think more about the
processes involved in creating art and
how AI machine learning can be involved
in that so harm fund and DARPA
used genetic algorithms to try and come
up with a supreme artwork so he has this
website where there are various title
drawings that are being generated and he
has two parent artworks that generate
lots of children artworks and then the
viewer then kind of chooses which one to
keep and then kind of continue the
process and in the end when all the
generated artworks are very similar the
the final artwork is then caps and can
be printed into a real 3d artwork
there's kind of this process of
narrowing down the options to come up
with the best supreme artwork so that's
some of his work of the potential
options that are generated and then
there was Nicolas McRae and Maria ostrov
suka who you have this project called
predictive art bot and this is a Twitter
bot that generates
concepts for artworks such as this one a
feminist land art piece divulging
classified information about online
dating or a post Internet malware to
materialize the bias of whistleblowers
so all these kind of semi random
concepts but if you're from the art
world you realize that these actually
can become real real works of art and
what the artists behind this project
wants to do is they got the machine to
generate the concept and then the
artists were supposed to realize that
and there were some projects where the
artist made I think various videos
according to kind of the title but there
was somewhat less interesting I don't
know how many of you are into like 3d
printing and stuff but there is this
website called Thingiverse that has
various 3d designs that you can print
and the artist Julian de swerve and Matt
Plummer Fernandez they created a bot
called ship integer that creates mashups
of various projects so here you see for
example this is one of these mashups
it's called an open Overlord nozzle and
you can see that it's a weird object
they probably would never come up with
yourself but hey that's what the bot
does by combining various designs and to
me it was interesting to see the
feedback from the community because
there was this bot that kept creating
these designs and on the newsfeed they
kind of kept coming up and some people
were not sure if it was done by human
who maybe needed to communicate in some
way others were complaining that it was
quite spammy and yeah others were just
remark about it was strange or it helped
them and in the end
combinated an exhibition in the
netherlands where all these generated
works were printed and then people could
vote whether this is art or spam and
it's mainly vetted as art but that's
mainly because people who go to art
galleries do like art I don't know
spam okay well and then if we think
about kind of some of the critical art
done with AI then I often think of an
artist called constant alert who worked
with with the technologist to do the
opposite of deep dream so deep dream
emphasizes the features in an image like
we saw in the beginning and this dull
dream it's reduced as the features in an
image so you can see this is quite
blurry and the same with Trump and
constant dillard wanted to show here how
we as individuals can kind of regain
control of our privacy and make
ourselves a little bit less recognizable
by producing features and I don't know
if you saw this
so yeah this probably needs a little
explanation but Scott Kelly and Ben
Polkinghorne decided that it's good to
comment on the way we are kind of
obsessed with our online lives and
searching for recommendations so why not
put up boards like this in New Zealand
so that people know where else they
might want to go while it's there in
this beautiful natural environment and
while you're in a beach you can go to
some other beaches when you're in a
playground you can go to McDonald's yeah
so I quite like this and then if we're
still thinking about the theme of kind
of privacy and hiding away from these
computer vision and image and facial
recognition systems then the artist Adam
Harvey created a work called CV dazzle
and yeah this work shows what you can do
what you can kind of put on your face to
make yourself unrecognizable as a face
to some of these models and I think
these are a little bit out of date
because of course the technologists keep
being updated but it's interesting that
at one point if you put something on
your cheeks you no longer became a face
or if you had these can weird hairstyles
yeah and finally I wanted to look at
some projects that imagine what art or
living in now in a world with AI would
look like so there is Ian Chang that has
an emissaries trilogy that is a kind of
a live simulation of various kind of
actors existing in this
space and there is there is Lawrence Lac
who made a film called geomancer that is
set in a singapore of I think 2050 and
is about a satellite AI that wants to
become an artist and yes so when when
creating this film
Lawrence used teri broad and his
variational auto encoder to generate a
dream sequence in the film so the
original film was done in this kind of
game engine style and this is a shot
from the dream sequence that is also
kind of can be seen here and yeah this
is to show that this is maybe what an AI
of the future dreams like this is what
it sees or visualizes yeah and then
there is an artist called Jake elves who
[Music]
who has this artwork called closed loop
and he has two models so one is a
captioning model so think it's the one
on the right and it tries to come up
with a caption for what it sees on the
left and then the the model on the left
it tries to generate an image based on
the caption so it's like - AI is talking
to each other and if you watch this for
a long period of time you will see that
it gets stuck and I don't know either a
color or some sort of animal thematic
it's in this case there's a lot of blue
and birds artists such as Helen Knowles
are thinking about some of the legal and
ethical implications of living with AI
and what Helen knows did is she came up
with with a fictional scenario of
of when there was this kind of algorithm
that suggested that students take some
sort of take part in medical experiments
and then one or two of those students
died and then the algorithm that
suggested this was put on trial and say
Helen Knowles filmed this trial and you
could also experience it as a
performance if you went to the gallery
as a viewer so she had a combination of
computer scientists lawyers and other
kind of individuals relevant to the
field discuss it and I think it's it's
always quite curious what what this
would just what the discussions come out
to and I think there is also a different
depending on whether it was kind of live
or recorded and then there is Tina
Yothers who has a work called the Kitty
AI that is yeah that is about an AI that
becomes the first governor of the planet
and it's represented as a cat it's a
talking cat that talks about the future
and the inevitability of could have been
unable to resist the various problems
like human society faces and yeah if you
want to see more of more AI based
artworks then you can go to this website
called nips for creativity calm and
there are about 50 different works
submitted to the nips workshop I
organized last year and if you happen to
be in Leicester I'm organizing a short
AI and art festival there for the next
two weeks and we have a couple of
installations and some talks yeah
including the the cacique eye
installation and yeah if you're doing
some research in the area or if you're
experimenting with
these tools then you should come or
submit to our computer vision for
fashion Art and Design workshop which is
going to happen as part of a European
conference on computer vision in Munich
on the 14th of September so we don't
have an official open call yet but keep
an eye out for it and yeah here are my
contact details if you want to reach out
and if you have an artwork or anything
you'd like to call to my attention
any questions
[Applause]
there is a question okay
any questions
thank you it was super super interesting
I have two questions first one this is
like good examples of that but what is
the criticism of people in art about
this new direction of AI in art second
one for example if I want to do
something like that how can I find
funding to basically buy food and like
that the way to monetize these things
okay yeah so two very good questions so
number one is kind of how I guess the
art world perceives it and that really
depends so I think recently the art
world started to become very interested
in this topic of AI well like everybody
else right so there were a number of
exhibitions looking at the topic but
most of these exhibitions focus more on
the ethical dimensions of the topic so I
showed this artist Adam Harvey a
constant Delage who think about the
privacy and kind of hiding from this
civilians or facial recognition
algorithms so I think a lot of the works
that are appreciated by the art
community they are those that are a bit
kind of critical of this system and the
role the technology companies play in
our world and yeah a lot of the artists
I mentioned here they're not always
recognized by the art world because
sometimes the art world thinks that
there should be more of a focus on kind
of meaning and more of a critical kind
of thinking about this technology but
yeah I think sometimes that is changing
and artists such as Mario Clingerman
Jake Alves and Anna Riddler I have seen
their work exhibited and various museum
exhibitions and to answer your second
point so how do you get funding
I think today I tweeted there was that
there's a museum in Shanghai that is
doing a three-month fellowship for
artists who want to come and kind of
working on AI based project and I think
in general you have to look for grants
or kind of open calls that are released
by various museums and related
institutions so I also know Google are
some culture they had a fellowship and
an open call for that a few months back
and although these do keep coming up
it's not kind of too frequent and
generally there is a lot of competition
also from established artists so
probably one of the best ways of kind of
getting into this field is starting out
kind of as a hobbyist and submit and
keep submitting your work kind of online
just to Twitter and then also to the
various kind of open cause that for
example Iran with nips or ICI CV because
that will increase your visibility and
yeah I probably suggest funding the art
through some of your other work well
there is no money in art so yeah ever
since the 60s to engage with the
commercial art world and what would be
an example of a of an organization or
artists who are really successful at
engaging with the commercial art world
and in terms of the commercial art world
how do you define that for you
okay okay and well okay yes saying if
you do kind of look at the yeah the
commercial side of the art world with
kind of your galleries auction houses
then I think there are various projects
for selling kind of digital art but in
general it is tricky and I like off the
top of my head I can't really think of
many artists who have been particularly
successful in that and I think there are
of course various artists such as Reggie
Kara who might create various
installations and performances and once
can have they become big names that way
they're paid a lot for commissions but
in actually kind of selling digital arts
I I do think it's tricky thank you is
there was an interesting so I have a
question a bit different you didn't
reinvention about I'm curious how
artists managed to actually use like
deep learning like because I guess some
of them at least one we know so much
about like software or like machine
learning so like how do they use those
tools like because do they use it as a
black box do they sometimes write a
little bit more because even machine
owner sometimes don't understand zaimes
I was a bit interested in to the tool
aspect and how they use a tool for this
kind of art works you presented yeah so
this depends on on the artist so I
presented you like for the variety of
examples and I would say there are
probably three main categories so the
first category might have people such as
memo actin who play around with
these tools and yet they also work on
developing some of these models and can
ya tweak them very easily themselves and
they publish in the top conferences as
well then on the other side of the
spectrum you have artists who are
curious about the space such as Anna
Riddler or Georgia whaddaya and they
there for example they take one of jeans
Jean kurgans machine learning for art
workshops so they know kind of the
basics of the technology but yeah it is
mostly a black box for them initially
and then they might start kind of
developing the knowledge further but
they are far from developing their own
models they do sometimes ask for
assistance and then in the middle you
have people such as constant delights
and lauren slack who work with
technologists such as Adam Harvey or
turns broad to create or to add an
element of what created by by by deep
learning technology into their artwork
that is often a bit more kind of
conceptually heavy so that's how I would
categorize it any final question no one
more last one
hey thanks for the great talk so you
talked about the the art from the point
of view of the artist what do you think
of the blurring of the artist tool
boundary and where do you think that's
headed or what what's the general
consensus on that in the art community
whether the AI here is an artist or a
tool yes so I think in general it is a
tool and in my view and from speaking to
many of the artists is just really the
media that likes to ride the AI created
I don't know the first drawing in this
particular category or made some other
achievement because that's kind of what
gets clicks right and that's what the
media want but if you do talk to artists
then I mean yeah then you see that the
yeah yeah yeah the the deep learning
techniques are used as a tool right
because you decide that oh you want to
use this particular model then you pick
your datasets then you kind of tweak the
parameters and figure out kind of what
you want your generated output to look
like and then finally you also curate it
right so I think the human is still too
involved into the various stages of the
process for it to be purely called AI
art kind of as a it's kind of as done by
AI completely thank you very much for
that wonderful talk and the insight into
AI and art and please give it up give it
up for Lou buck
you